dans le château de fanta myla rose sa
vie une très belle princesse elle va
avoir 18 ans et le terrible sort qui lui
fut jetée à sa naissance va pouvoir
s'éteindre le pays sera enfin libérée
c'est ce que tu crois
bienvenue à tous sur la chaîne du petit
chaperon ce soir l'endroit où il faut
être
c'est sur ce tapis rouge je vois arriver
le chat botté qui veut faire la souris
sont les sénat qu en face de toi
très bientôt j'aurai ma revanche
je me demande comment elle comptait me
piquer le doigt avec ça je le dis tout
alors appuyé ou à la mort baiser
pourquoi est ce que tout le monde est
endormi tout ça c'est ma faute et ça
aurait même pu être encore pire pour
délibérer cac je veux que tu fasse
redescendre tout de suite
non
il n'y a qu'une chose à faire foncez les
yeux fermés et beaune est vraiment
devrait si elle vous trouvez qu'on
ressemble à des filles on est chamane
herbages les deux très gros vous êtes
verte à vouloir y aller les crocs mais
on a fait trop qu'une chance mais on va
quand même la tente et je me demande si
ces créatures
mais qu'est ce qu'elle a fait à jack je
suis jack
coup franc plein bernard
oh